c'est le moment de l'introduction jours
aujourd'hui on est à voir l'intérêt
commun c'est electronic arts qui
m'envoie à l'esa pour suivre un
entraînement d'astronautes à l'occasion
de la sortie de mass effect andromeda
honore le jeu bien sûr ils ont des
technologies de la plus avancée que nous
actuellement
mais cela n'empêche qu'ils sont dans
l'espace et qu'aujourd'hui on va faire
ce [ __ ] entraînements que les
astronautes source avant d'aller dans
l'espace
et croyez moi il est lourd mais avant ça
va faire un tour de l'endroit
directement je t'aime mon amour
[Musique]
m
les amis c'est ouf on est dans une
reproduction d'un module de liesse à ses
dents productions fidel c'est à dire
quand tu vas vraiment alias as ya un
[ __ ] de modules qui exactement comme
ça on a par exemple si une transition
vers un autre module pour que les
ivoiriens on y va à pied comme des
merdes qu'on est sur une station
spatiale mais en fait duc vu que les
modules ont été envoyés dans l'espace il
ya des dizaines d'années
ben on voit que c'est un peu vieilli t
au niveau de la gueule que ça c'est un
truc future is love avec des hologrammes
c'est faux retour à la réalité en fait
ici on est dans le hall d'entraînement
donc ses peurs de reproduction de
modules comme ici les astronomes
viennent ici pendant des années
s'entraîner à faire des actions qui vont
refaire là haut mais sur la vraie ya 16
dans les vrais module mais qu'ils ont
pas droit à l'erreur ils ont un
entraînement de malade mental ya un
cycle en fait d'entraînement pour
devenir astronaute tu dois être
sélectionné ok ensuite tu vas continuer
de s'entraîner pendant entre une et cinq
années et ensuite il faut qu'ils aient
une mission pour toi en fait une mission
donnée et quand ils sont quand même
préparer une mission il crée un équipage
thomas pesquet par exemple il est je
crois qu'il est avec un américain et un
japonais est lui s'est entraîné pendant
cinq ans ici avant de partir donc le mec
il est rodé je pense qu'il sait tout
faire actuellement lui donne un caillou
il fabrique un pc c'est sûr et c'est
démission de six mois nous faut ce dire
qu'il a trouvés ils vont passer six mois
dans des trucs aussi et trois en fait
dans l'espace veine des boyz quoi [ __ ]
j'y arriverai pas franchement c'est
super donc ils font leur mission ils
reviennent sur terre et repasse en mode
entraînement régulier jusqu'à ce qu'on
leur ait attribué une nouvelle mission
pour le réintègre dans un nouvel
équipage qui peut être le même que leurs
précédents et qui repartent
voilà c'est l'histoire d'un astronaute
ce que thomas pesquet est en train de
vivre aujourd'hui finalement les amis on
a trouvé le poste de simulation de
pilotage de soyouz en fait pendant des
années ils sont tannés s'entraîne
notamment à conduire le truc qui va leur
permettre d'atteindre les ss je t'ai
bien de s'entraîner mais s'ils
n'arrivent pas à atteindre les 16 bat ça
sert pas à grand chose
j'espère qu'il fit ou la cia genre en
particulier mais c'était joystick
d'accord ok mais en fait eu carrément
trop tard
ça c'est pour les avant bras et tu fais
ton petit créneau comme ça après vu
qu'on est habitué aux jeux vidéo tu vois
la rejoignait c'est ça les mecs c'est
trop bien comment ils sont en bas ah ben
si l'on dise jugé dans la gamme danse
thomas et conduisait le dollar joue à
dofus sur les frontières un écran belle
avec une petite souris je me casse sur
les 16 membres
[Musique]
ici c'est le poste du rock sommes donc
communicateur européen et le but du jeu
pour les yeux ronds comme c'est d'être
la voix de l'équipe la flight couple
team l'équipe de vol sur terre qui
s'occupe du module européen columbus
suivi qu'il ya quelque chose qui se
passe dans columbus il ya un lion comme
qui va être là pour transmettre des
informations
recevoir comme ce qui se passe
actuellement voilà losail à péguy qui
vient d'appeler que les ententes
directes tant leur conversation dérive
placée en direct c'est donc là ce qu'on
voit les images des astronautes ceci en
direct c'est notre français bon bah
merci pour tout ma loge et maire de tard
par les guérit pas le français ça m'a
fait super plaisir
et puis en plus c'est hyper intéressant
quoi c'est que les stars sont ceux qui
sont dans l'espace en fait il ya
carrément autant de stars qui sont au
sol ici et qui les aident et qui les
assiste et qui prépare ce voyage avec
elle en fait
et du coup bravo en tout cas pour ce que
tu fais et puis bonne continuation merci
grand soin de notre thomas avec les amis
c'est ouf on est libre une piscine de 10
mètres de profondeur dans laquelle se
trouve une reproduction du module
columbus ils vont là dedans en tenue
d'astronautes et a fait ça simule une
vraie sortie extravéhiculaire dans
l'espace et la simulation la plus proche
de la vraie situation qu'on n'arrive pas
à créer un espace où il ya pas de
gravité sur terre c'est impossible donc
on fait ça sous l'eau voilà ça les
antennes de ouf et vous répéter répéter
répéter les mêmes mouvements encore
encore et encore pour que le jour où il
le fasse pour de vrai dans l'espace eh
ben ça foire partons va se changer pour
faire la plonge et ma combinaison
d'hommes qui va aller dans l'espace sous
l'eau c'est trop cool c'est ce collector
qu'à arrêter car c'est vous qui me
transporte en astronaute à les rp za de
la france mon gars opus maîtres somme
une fois dans l'île et celles ci sont
totalement en mode tee shirt blanc et
petit jogging gris très important au
yacht club ont pu en avoir
on va pas mettre sa ok je suis fier
d'être français je vais représenter
notre pays un magma brûlant doyer sommes
allés let's go va je crois qu'on va nous
briefer avant de plonger ce qui est
selon moi un peu nécessaire pour
nozari jours on avait super v hervé que
fais tu ici hervé ici je suis
instructeur pour les assauts de la
gestion européenne pour les sorties
extravéhiculaires quand on bat deux en
un espace way et depuis cette salle de
contrôle puisque on vas t'entraîner je
gère les opérations et je m'assure que
tout se passe bien soin des yeux partout
exactement exactement et je suis comme
l'astronaute dans la station spatiale
qui vérifie que ses copains extérieurs
font un bon boulot ça marche à 3 du coût
non va être jeu à sortir lentement toi
tu vas être celui qui contrôle le tout
cas distance du bois surtout qui bien
acquis en cas de pépin peut nous aider
exactement je vote pour vous aider vous
a préparé un petit exercice tu m'as dis
ça mais tout à fait on va aller voir ça
c'est juste à côté
allez je te suis enfin de coutume
c'est là qu'ils ont
énergie
les maquettes et donc nous on va pas
défendre a dit m non vous allez
descendre profond qui nous serait quand
même immergé way pour des raisons de
sécurité parce qu'on n'avait pas eu
d'informations préliminaires oui bien
sûr nez
les activités qui t'attendait ce truc
que tu admires à va faire du bon travail
voici le paquebot travail exactement
donc comme un astronaute dans l'espace
vous allez devoir installer un
équipement qui en fait l'expérience avec
une antenne comme une antenne radar
d'accord vous regardez l'environnement
extérieur de la terre et cette boîte qui
vous allez devoir l'amener l'installer
ici l'accroché a versé pour cherokee à
eruh ok ça la maintient à rire sans
toucher les radiateurs qui sont way
faire des connexions électriques
d'accord et donc cesser le taf que des
atomes outre exhortera emporté le
travail qui leur est ensuite qui hors
alimentaire une antenne à prendre que
vous allez installer au dessus ok on
installe dedans claque dans sa marche il
va falloir la fixer pour éviter qu'elles
s'envolent pour la fixer vous allez
utiliser des outils des houthis tout est
attaché parce qu'on est sous l'eau une
forcément symbole si on n'attache pas
vérifié que la configuration est bonne
ouais mettre la puissance s'est jamais
éloigné ont bu tout en rupture sur
l'attribution des trois curés on va
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui et donc la
difficulté c'est que pour faire comme ça
voici ton pire ennemi
un gant qui fait que tu as des doigts
qui font trois fois la taille des doigts
normalement et du coup manipuler avec ça
c'est très très dur en fait on a essayé
juste avant et c'est un calvaire mais je
pense que ça va le faire on va garder la
confiance mutuelle faire et voilà hervé
la confiance du coup j'ai confiance à
bruxelles je suis en train d'enfiler ma
seconde peau qui va me permettre de
pénétrer dans le bassin hyper au présent
littéralement caniza thomas je pense
trois fois parce que j'ai caleçon qui
rendement est facile peut dire c'est
très désagréable
allez ce parti c'est le moment d'y aller
je pars pas avec david mon pote
l'espagnol qui fait la mission avec moi
dans mon masque en fait il est connecté
on est relié aussi au tour de contrôle
juste là où notre troisième poteau donne
donne les instructions sur les oublie
que david et fiona laisse d'osys
big screen moment mike shanahan
nous
il ya deux ans
que du beau monde
le président
chaque semaine juste un match heurté
sur l'est
keith ellison vélo au québec
black screen of death paul le guen évite
une copie conforme des deux poings isos
squeeze de pégase news from mission
control russie de télémétrie ce congrès
jobs
20e les amis je viens de sortir de
l'expérience de la mission qui a sauvé
la terre apparemment il y avait stéphane
et hervé qui me parlait dans le masque
est en fait on entend assez bien sauf
quand on explique on n'entend rien du
tout
êtes vous quand même parler je devais
arrêter de l'espérer bossé pendant 20
secondes respirer comme un gros porc et
là on parle et je pouvais pas arrêter de
s p est dense mourir et deuxième
difficulté c'est que tu peux pas voir si
40 sous toit et qu'à un moment je me
suis accroché à david
je l'adoré mais jma avait exploité je
pensais que c'était son mousqueton et je
la rangée en lui rendant un prophète
c'était le mien rester une expérience
incroyable c'était ouf
et on se rend compte de la difficulté du
truc mais c'est dur mais c'est c est ça
que le début et c'est prévu
mission réussie merci d'une habitation
est génial fière de toi non merci ça me
fait très plaisir et aller maintenant on
va changer on va s'assécher et on va les
enlever
[Musique]
on commence à l'entraînement je vous
présente la tl rc le bâtiment de
l'agencé spatiale allemande
c'est dans ce bâtiment qu'on va faire
l'entraînement d'aujourd'hui en fait
c'est surtout un bâtiment de recherche
médicale je vais sortir parce que ça met
mal à l'aise non qu'ils y font pas mal
d'expérience et ils ont un laboratoire
physiologique à laboratoire
psychologique et un laboratoire
biologique les mets qui bombardent en
tous cas d'étude et dernier set et les
centrifugeuses qu'ils ont mis au point
parce que vu que leur corps n'est pas
soumis à la gravité et ben leurs muscles
s'atrophie finalement il ya plein de
trucs qui ne fonctionne plus comme quand
son corps est soumis à la gravité et du
coup il essaie d'entretenir sa tombe n'a
pas levé le même c'est que quand tu
pourrais quand tu fais du sport l'a
quand même des muscles ne sont pas
sollicités et ton corps modifie quand
même sa manière de fonctionner et à long
terme et aimerait en fait mettre ça dans
l' iss dans la sienne de la station
spatiale internationale pour en fait
simuler la gravité grâce à la force
centrifuge et ça permettra à tous ces
petits bus ne sont pas sollicités mal le
fait qu'elle fasse deux heures de sport
et ben de bien se porter et comme ça
leur retour sur terre se répand
douloureux et maintenant on va arrêter
de parler et on va aller s'entraîner
je veux dire si je ressens au capteur
qui suis je
des matchs je faisais mais là on va
tester le sport façon astronautes comme
ils font là aura pas tout cas pas de
vérité vérité qui les maintiennent vers
un tapis c'est un peu une structure
autre chose qu'une chose la seule crise
enfin il m'avait pas en allemand pas
compris du tout ce qui est dit
[Musique]
elle sur les jambes diaraf l'obligeront
le kilométrage
jean des jambettes ces chocs de
on y chante en allemand
warsh roanne avant ça fait les musiques
fait trois pas plus que son
un format le plus bas c'est normal
mme allard était ok we are born
oh ça m'a flingué le cul un truc de ouf
mais je vous le marché quoi ça chez moi
c'est moi entrer chez moi si vous voulez
des biens de cette expérience mais
largement deux minutes quoi s'emballer
comme la plume ghassan al enfants
haïtiens
j'en peux plus mon espace tout ça je
peux plus lâche tient plus
[Musique]